- I couldn't get any entry
level job in my own company
'cause I couldn't pass the written test
or the math test for the two disciplines.
I couldn't.
I own the whole fuckin' thing
and the straight facts are
I could not work for my own
company in an entry level job.
(soft music)
- Were you always successful?
- In every thing but school.
- Didn't do well in school?
- Poor, terrible actually.
Punted it.
And this is where I give
my parents enormous credit.
Education's the way out for immigrants.
- Sure is.
- My mom recognized that I was
a merchant, an entrepreneur.
And then when I got D's
and F's, she punished me.
Even though she knew I didn't
need school, in her heart,
she made me know that there
was accountability for things.
The biggest problem
right now is insecurity.
Everybody's actions are to get shit
to close their insecurity.
You've so much time and
everybody's in such a rush.
They're in a rush because they want
to prove something to somebody.
Money is not the variable of happiness.
To me, life is broken down
into complaining and not.
So if you're not complaining,
well then I have no advice for you.
I'm pumped, you did it.
I just don't understand people
dwelling and complaining.
Like listen, I really really
really would have enjoyed
being the quarterback of the New York Jets
but by fourth grade I looked
around, I'm like, fuck,
I'm not gonna be the
quarterback of the Jets.
(audience laughing)
And so I said, you know what?
Instead of being the
quarterback of the Jets,
I'm gonna buy the Jets.
There's so many people
that are talking shit
about how big of an
entrepreneur they're gonna be
and how much they're gonna achieve
and they don't work on weekends.
The reason I do a daily vlog on YouTube
is don't listen to what I'm saying,
watch what I'm doing.
I want to make patience
and empathy and gratitude
and eating fuckin' dog
shit for 15 years, cool.
Period.
Because that's the only
way they're gonna get it.
- Right.
- You know I worked every
Saturday in my 20's.
I don't sit on my couch and
say, I'm gonna be a millionaire
and then jerk off while
I'm playing Madden all day.
People want all these
special things to happen,
but then they're acting
like everybody else.
And that gets into the
Saturdays in your 20's.
Or just taking risks or
things of that nature.
This shit's fuckin' binary.
Either you do the shit that
gets you there or you don't.
And everybody's focused
on the finish line,
not the treadmill work and
drinkin' the fuckin' egg
like Rocky fuckin' Balboa.
They don't want to do that shit.
- So what should we do, Gary Vee?
- People should stop
fuckin' stop complaining.
People should figure out
who the fuck they are.
You've got to figure out how to try shit.
Like that's the only, you just never know
what your favorite food
was until you tried it.
You only had chicken
you might not have known
that hot dogs were the best.
So, that's what I love about the internet.
These kids have so much option
to watch shit on YouTube.
My only answer, is just, try shit.
The reason most people who
are listening right now
are not doing that thing,
is they're worried about
the opinion of somebody,
usually their mother,
usually their father.
And the reality is is that your spouse
may be the person holding you back
and you have to have that conversation.
- Do you feel like you judge yourself?
- I don't.
And it's what I want for everybody else.
We're beating ourselves up.
Everybody sucks at something.
Right?
Like we all have short comings.
And we all have strengths.
And for me it's like why
don't we just audit that.
You have to love hard.
You have to love eating shit.
You have to love people leaving comments
saying, you suck.
You have to love the process.
Figure out what your fuckin' thing is
and stop making fucking bullshit excuses
who the President is, your mom did this,
I missed it, I had that idea for Uber.
Then why didn't you fuckin' do it, dick?
People decide no before they try.
You just decided no because
the system tells you no.
You've been sold no.
If you're lucky enough
right now to be listening
and you're good at what you like,
become tunnel fuckin' vision.
Because there's way too
many voices telling you
what and how.
I want the pain.
I want the process.
I have the patience.
I don't care when I have setbacks.
I know that I'm asking
for something special.
And if you're asking for something special
it should be hard.
Everybody's saying no.
I just say yes.
And then if it's a no,
I don't give a fuck.
You gonna judge me that I lost?
I don't give a fuck what you think.
And that's why I get so into that.
Because then you're not scared to try shit
because when you don't give a fuck
what everybody says about you failing.
You love failing.
I love the music.
Own your shortcomings.
Own your strengths.
Surround yourself with the other shit
and stuff starts to pop.
Thank you for having me.
(audience applauding)